Tywin Lannister: Rhaegar Targaryen lay dead
on the banks of the Trident, his royal army
shattered and in retreat.
The days of the dragon kings were clearly
numbered.
Until that moment it would have been foolish
to commit Casterly Rock to either the crown
or the rebellion.
What would our family have to gain in supporting
a raving madman or in entering a crusade to
put Robert Baratheon on the Iron Throne?
But chaos benefits no one.
It was time for House Lannister to do what
it could to ensure a return of peace and prosperity
to the land.
I, Tywin Lannister, brought ten thousand Lannister
troops to the gates of King's Landing, in
order to bring the bloodshed to a quick and
decisive conclusion.
King Aerys had been sending ravens for months
begging for my support to end the uprising.
In a way, his pleas had been answered.
As I had suspected, Aerys opened the city
gates and welcomed my men.
Our plan was clear: crush Aerys's remaining
bannermen and remove the remnants of the royal
family as quickly and efficiently as possible.
Any alternative meant years of further war
and a fragmented Seven Kingdoms.
Our means were bloody, but the results speak
for themselves.
As for Aerys, it is true he met his fate at
the hands of my son.
Aerys had kept Jaime close during the rebellion,
thinking himself clever in keeping my son
as a hostage - should I decide to pledge support
to the rebel cause.
This proved to be his greatest mistake, for
when the time came Jaime did his duty as a
Lannister... and drove his sword into the
Mad King's back.
With that, Robert Baratheon's crown was secured.
The new king recognized our role in his ascension
to the throne, just as he recognized how useful
the might and riches of Casterly Rock would
be... if he wanted to keep it.
To that end, I offered my daughter Cersei
as his queen.
Had Aerys not spurned this same offer years
earlier, perhaps things would have worked
out differently.
With Robert and Cersei crowned as King and
Queen of the Seven Kingdoms, it was a new
day.
The dragon was vanquished, and the Seven Kingdoms
would thereafter belong to the stag... and
the lion.
Robert Baratheon: For our rebellion to succeed,
King's Landing had to be taken, forcefully.
No one was foolish enough to believe that
Aerys was gonna hand his crown over peacefully.
The Mad King's reign needed to end.
What Tywin Lannister's forces did was unfortunate,
but it was necessary to secure the Iron Throne
and bring peace and justice to the Seven Kingdoms.
My glorious victory at the Trident left me
wounded, but I sent my personal maester to
attend to Ser Barristan Selmy instead; his
wounds were more severe.
Even though Ser Barristan was a member of
Aerys'sKingsguard and fought on the opposing
side, that man's bravery and loyalty were
something to behold.
But this meant my wounds would take longer
to heal and I couldn't ride to King's Landing
myself.
I sent the one man I trusted over anyone else
in this world, Ned Stark, in my place.
Had I been able to ride, perhaps I could have
reached King's Landing sooner and prevented
some of the violence that occurred when the
Lannisters entered the city.
Still, what Lord Tywin did was for the greater
good.
Even what happened to Princess Elia and her
children.
Babies or no, theirs was the same cursed blood
that flowed within the Mad King's veins.
They were dragonspawn and couldn't be allowed
to survive.
What would they grow to be?
Loyal subjects?
Ned, with his damn northern honor.
He and I had our first major fight over the
deaths of the Targaryen children.
Ned called it murder.
Murder!?
It was war!...
It was war...
Lord Stark demanded that the Lannisters be
held responsible for their crimes.
Was it a crime to put an end to a family of
lunatics born of incest?
I wouldn't - and still won't - blame Tywin.
Instead, I sent Ned Stark south to finish
off the remaining Targaryen loyalists.
It was only Lyanna Stark's death that reconciled
us.
Ned had lost his sister.
I had lost my betrothed and beloved.
We shared that sad bond together, Ned and
I.
Through it, our friendship was made strong
again.
Viserys Targaryen: The Battle of the Trident
may have been an important victory for the
Usurper, but it was the treachery and barbarism
of Tywin Lannister that sealed the fate of
the Targaryen dynasty.
My father, King Aerys, had ever been a friend
to the Lions of the Rock.
Aerys graciously brought Tywin to court, making
him the youngest Hand of the King in history.
He gave him power.
He gave him respect.
He made it possible for Tywin to restore House
Lannister to glory.
Aerys and Tywin governed side by side for
twenty prosperous years.
Still, when the Usurper called his banners
in rebellion, Tywin Lannister ignored his
king's pleas for help and stayed holed up
in his stronghold of Casterly Rock.
In time, my brother Prince Rhaegar was dead.
The realm was in turmoil.
And the Usurper's forces were said to be riding
for King's Landing.
What a glorious sight it must have been when
a force of ten thousand Lannister men showed
up at the gate of the capital with Lord Tywin
at their head, pledging support to his beleaguered
king.
Aerys opened the gates for his old friend.
Instead, Lannister and his men proceeded to
plunder and destroy the city that he had called
home for decades.
As the capital was ravaged and its people
terrorized, Jaime Lannister, son of Lord Tywin,
proved every bit as treacherous.
He killed my father, the king, at the foot
of the Iron Throne.
The Lannisters entered the Red Keep and Tywin
ordered the deaths of the rest of the royal
family.
It is said Princess Rhaenyswas found cowering
under her father's bed and put to the sword.
She was only a child.
As for Rhaegar's widow, Elia, she was forced
to watch as Lannister thugs dashed her baby
son's head against a wall, before being murdered
herself.
As I was the heir to my father's throne, I
had been spirited away to Dragonstone with
my mother, Queen Rhaella, who was with child.
As a raging summer storm battered the island
fortress and destroyed the Targaryen fleet
as it lay at anchor, my sister Daenerys was
born.
My mother, the queen, died giving birth.
MaesterLuwin: Robert Baratheon's victory at
the Trident was a turning point in the war
for the Iron Throne.
While it was clear the gods were smiling on
the rebel forces, Aerys Targaryen still held
the Red Keep at King's Landing.
As Robert was wounded and unable to ride,
it was up to Eddard Stark to make for the
capital and force the Mad King to give up
the throne.
Lord Stark reached the city gates to find
that Tywin Lannister, Lord of Casterly Rock,
had already sacked the city in Robert's name.
House Lannister had remained neutral up to
this point, ignoring requests for help from
both the crown and the rebels.
Now that Robert's eventual victory was assured,
it seemed Lord Tywin had finally chosen a
side.
Lord Eddard was horrified by what he saw when
he entered the city - homes looted and burned,
scores of innocent citizens killed.
Disgusted, he led his force up Visenya's Hill
to the Red Keep.
Upon entering the throne room, he found King
Aerys lying in a pool of blood... dead, by
the hand of his own sworn Kingsguard, Jaime
Lannister - who sat brazenly upon the throne.
Demanding to know the whereabouts of Queen
Rhaella, Lord Eddard was informed the queen
and her son Viserys had been spirited away
to Dragonstone before the Lannisters arrived.
But other members of the royal family were
not as fortunate.
Elia Martell of Dorne, who was the wife of
Prince Rhaegar, had been murdered by Ser Gregor
Clegane on Lord Tywin's orders.
Ser Gregor and his men had also butchered
Rhaegar's young children.
When Robert was well enough to reach the capital,
Lord Eddard demanded the Lannisters answer
for their heinous crimes.
Robert refused and sent himself to relieve
the Baratheon stronghold of Storm's End, which
was still under siege by forces loyal to the
crown.
Whatever words passed between the two old
friends are known only to them, but Lord Eddard
is said to have left King's Landing in anger.
Later, when Robert was crowned, he appointed
Jon Arryn as Hand of the King.
Lord Arryn's first order of business was to
broker a truce with the Martells of Dorne,
who were outraged by the brutal murder of
Princess Elia and her children.
Following the death of Lyanna Stark, who had
been betrothed to Robert, Houses Baratheon
and Lannister were joined in marriage when
the new king took Tywin Lannister's eldest
daughter, Cersei, as his queen.
As for Eddard Stark, he returned to his stronghold
of Winterfell, forever haunted by his sister's
death, and the shameful way that Robert had
secured his throne.